au bord de la loire le camping de gien
n'est toujours pas sorti de sa torpeur
les 200 emplacements sont quasiment
vides et les prévisions sont tout aussi
morose pour la fin du printemps et le
début de l'été et bien voila l'exemple
type d'un planning pour l'année 2000 21
alors tous les blancs et bien ces deux
personnes
et maintenant je vais vous faire voir un
exemple de planning 2019 et vous voyez
ça passe ça se passe de commentaire
ça c'est un planning une année normale
la baisse de fréquentation entre 2019 et
2020 s'établit à -45% dans ce camping
une catastrophe financière qui a
nécessité le recours à toutes les aides
disponibles pour survivre et pour
retrouver des images semblables à celles
d'avant la crise sanitaire le secteur
touristique salue le dispositif de
l'état permettant l'embauché dès
maintenant des saisonniers avec un
recours au chômage partiel jusqu'au
redémarrage effectif de l'activité
un coup de pouce non négligeable mais
qui n'efface pas tous les soucis
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas
combien de temps le dispositif
d'ouverture des terrasses à 50% leurs
jauges va durer a qu'à partir de quel
moment on pourra utiliser l'intérieur
mais peut-être les établissements et
dans quelles capacités
donc effectivement ce dispositif va
permettre d'embaucher des saisonniers
mais on n'a pas la notion de quantité
saisonniers qu'on pourra embaucher par
établissement des salades avocats ces
monts et vallées et l'enjeu est plus
large que l'emploi saisonnier puisque
c'est le maintien du nombre des salariés
de tout le secteur touristique qui est
en question
il a déjà chuté de 9 % en 2020 en centre
val de loire